I want to open it to the floor we have
so many smart and interesting people
here and Michael Elliot was was out
there somewhere Michael yeah you had a
question I wanted to make sure you got
it and just idea please identify
yourself back there hi I'm Mike Elliot
from Time magazine one of the unexpected
at least to me themes of the first day
of Davos yesterday was a crisis of
expensive food that was mentioned by
delegates from India from Africa and
from China and rightly or wrongly in
many parts of the developing world
that's associated with the increasing
amount of arable land that's devoted to
the production of ethanol
similarly Bono just earlier this morning
pointed out that in landlocked parts of
Africa and other parts of the world
air transport is an essential tool of
economic development I just like to ask
all of you how in practical terms do you
convince people in the developing world
that these two great goals of poverty
reduction and unclimbed change are not
in conflict I mean how do you convince
people the climate change will not be a
policy adopted on the back of people who
just recently have moved from one meal a
day to do can I just say I feel like one
of the biggest problems we have in the
world is people don't realize that
technology is the way we solve these
problems so I was giving a talk recently
and we have this great economist who
helped start Hal Varian um and he and I
was saying well he's saying basically
all the group growth in GDP per capita
has been to technology and you can graph
it it's like an exponential you know
starts with basically farm improvements
and mechanization and mass manufacturing
and so on and the way we're going to get
out of problems like that is by having
better technology and if you look at you
know the US has something like you have
10,000 people of the equivalent of
10,000 people helping you every day with
the energy use they're pushing your car
they're carrying your water to you if
you work out the number of calories
you'd have to use as a person
to do all the things that you do
something like 10,000 people in Africa
you know that numbers like 1 or 2 or not
or 0 right and you know really it's
really not fun to have to carry your
water it would be really nice to have
somebody carry your water for you and
the way we're gonna solve those problems
is by having more energy not loss and by
having it not hurt our environment the
world that we live in and by having it
be a whole lot cheaper right having more
having it be cheaper those things are
related the way we're going to do that
is with technology or not there's no
other magic that's gonna do it and
that's the way it's always been done and
if you look at the trends there's been
huge huge advances in all these things
so I think the the way you're gonna
solve poverty is by having helpers and
energy is a great way to have helpers if
the food cost is probably largely based
on transportation now the cost
transportation is largely based on the
cost of energy and so you know you saw
you'll solve both those problems at once
you'll solve food and you'll solve
energy and that will help with poverty
and starvation and all those things and
the way we're going to do that is we're
gonna make it cheap and prevalent and
you know you can deal a whole take a
whole anywhere in the world and get tons
of energy um that'd be a great thing
right let's let's go build that can I
make go ahead what I mean you know what
you've just heard from Larry was what I
think forced me to change my mind about
how you deal with climate change because
the the the logical extension of this
faith I think in technology and
engineering and not just faith but
historical record of it when we started
doing our energy work we were very
interested in renewables we were
interested in government policies and
Larry really challenged us he said um
you can't do it out of a feeling of
scarcity you can't you can't act just
out of conservation because then you
won't have economic development and you
will hurt so many people by any kind of
an abrupt slowdown or any kind of trade
off you're absolutely right about the
ethanol issue they're called chapatti
Wars now or tortilla Wars as people are
really rising up against ethanol for
that reason but Larry says don't make it
into a competition he says find a way to
make electricity not to have to cut back
on it but you have more than you ever
dreamed of and that you do it at prices
less than you ever thought of and you
know gird your loins get the engineers
by the way though the corn issue is
largely a public policy issue I mean the
reason why the corns expensive is
because we're making ethanol out of it
which we shouldn't be doing sorry
already mentioned we have 50% we have a
15 cent tariffs in the US on imported
ethanol and a 50% 50 cent subsidy on
corn ethanol so it's $1 a gallon
that's why corn is expensive it's not
because people would otherwise be making
an ethanol corn right right it is a
travesty that it is there's a 54 cent a
gallon tariff if you want to import
sugar ethanol from Brazil but if you
want to actually import a gallon of
refined gasoline from Saudi Arabia it's
only a penny and a half so from a
country in our hemisphere that's a
democracy we have a $0.54 tariff and
from the people who brought us 9/11 we
have a once-in- yeah I wanted to briefly
comment on Michael Elliot's question
first of all I wanted to compliment the
three of you for the equation re less
than C I think it's a brilliant and
simple clarification of the key moving
part in all of this debate but there's
actually a rich and growing literature
on the connection between food
insecurity in the developing world and
climate and the price of tortillas and
the price of other staples has actually
gone up more because of the
thousand-year drought in what many are
calling the thousand-year drought in
Australia and the effect on yields on
the supply side then on the very
marginal extra pressure that comes from
renewable fuels I happen to agree that
corn based ethanol is just a transition
dead in toward cellulosic ethanol and
and the use of enzymes enzymatic
hydrolysis is what that guys above my
pay grade but it's the the
I think one of the the winners on this
but but if you look at the map of where
the food it is to be grown in the
developing world the impact of climate
on this is by far the most important
issue the United Nations Development
Program has put out two reports now
Kevin Watkins the principal author says
the climate is the principal development
challenge and and the the program for
fighting against food insecurity has to
take account of climate in order to
succeed and by the way the trends in
agriculture in the developing the
poorest of the poor countries has been
monoculture the reason why as Larry
brilliant said the high percentage of
jobs is with the large multinationals is
because they're replacing the kind of
subsistence agriculture with locally
grown appropriate crops with these huge
plantations of monoculture that depend
upon lots of petroleum lots of
Transportation Juan Gauri Mata is a
green belt program got its notice for
tree planting but she uses that to
educate women primarily to go back to
the traditional crops that that are and
you know Alice Waters in the United
States has been among those who've who's
generated this this movement food and
security is one of the principal cutting
edges of the climate crisis in the in
the developing world and and and solving
it is yet another reason why we have to
intertwine this with the solutions to
the climate crisis one final point back
to the re less than C innovators
bringing renewable energy down in cost
represents the left-hand side of that
equation the right-hand side of the
equation is equally important the
externalities that are not presently
reflected in the price of coal and
fossil fuels have to be priced into this
equation but in order to reflect reality
and rather than seeing
as a tax it should be seen as a as a
revenue swap that all ought to come back
on the left-hand side of the equation
and in the form of adaptation not only
in the poorest of the poor countries but
among the poorest of the poor in the
rich countries thank you yes sir I'm
sorry okay to make a very quick comment
Judy Roden is here who runs the
Rockefeller Foundation and she sort of
been our inspiration and mentor they
have a hundred and fifty million dollar
program the Agra program which is to try
to deal with new seeds Gates puts them
most two thirds of the money in that is
because Africa never really had a green
revolution not in the way we think of
India having had one and because of
climate change you will see intercurrent
droughts and floods and salinity as salt
is brought from the rising seas over the
shores into agricultural land the
situation is so dire that for the first
time in known history farmers in Andhra
Pradesh and in parts of India committing
suicide because their lands will no
longer produce enough calories per
hectare to feed their family so Ellis in
my experience actually right these are
such twins of the same problem climate
change makes poverty worse poverty if it
does economic development wrong way
makes climate change worse we can't
choose sides we have to be both and yes
sir
yeah thanks I want to add one other
thing to this both and I don't know
whether to challenge Larry brilliant or
to ask a leading question of Sergey and
Larry but none of this if you think the
US government is short-sighted the the
other governments are so much worse that
they're there's a huge amount of
corruption in many of these countries
and it it four stalls thing you can have
business plans up the wazoo but now your
guy gets his $50,000 and the next thing
he knows the tax inspector comes calling
or he tries to open an office but it
gets closed down because some rich
landowner who's related to the nephew of
the governor
wants to start a shopping mall or
something like that and so in order for
for the top-down stuff to happen you
just need to go talk to the governments
but for most of the bottom-up stuff to
happen the stuff that's going to create
the diversity and the crops and the
entrepreneurs and all this economic
growth one way or another you do have to
take on these government's please
comment well I've actually Larry and I
have been talking about this issue a lot
I spent some time actually on in
Ethiopia the elections actually with the
Carter Center just monitoring elections
it's really interesting I recommend it
to people and they have really good
systems I mean you can debate the
election there but have really good
systems now for you know they have a
series of like 10 rules before they'll
goes all Larry's fault so you know keep
miscounted they have assists like oh
they have for example they have like 10
things they have to have before they'll
go into a country to monitor elections
and for example the u.s. I think needs
none of them by the way whereas the many
most of the country's newer countries
doing elections do meet those and you
know it's just about accountability you
know they everybody watches the ballot
box getting filled the ballot box
expands once they have the ballots they
write the numbers down on the building
so anyone can see them and you know if
you want to make sure that all the
tabulations were right you can just
visit all the buildings and I was sorry
I was I was gonna transition to that
sorry um I think that I think elections
are an area we can learn from because
there's been so much work done by a lot
of great people that there are actually
procedures in place now that we know if
we have the following 10 things then we
have an election that's probably mostly
fair or we know whether we did or not
and I think we need those set of 10
things for other parts of government so
you know there there's great
organizations that are trying to do
things like
measure you know if you're putting money
into a school does it actually get built
you know - can you see the school does
it have walls does it have books and
those kind of things how do you measure
that at scale and so you know what are
what are the ten things you need to do
to make sure when you gave the money for
the school but they really appear and
they have teachers and students and all
those things and I think if we get some
of those procedures and rules right for
these governments and we get the
accountability and the understanding of
what's going on I think we'll make a lot
of progress and around the corruption
side and so on my brother really likes
his phrase iso9000 for governments if
you go around in these developing
countries you see a factory they always
have an iso 9000 banner which is
basically you know this bureaucratic
stuff about how make sure that the stuff
you make is really what you claim it is
and it's safe and the bolts don't break
and if you build a building out of the
nails they don't you know your building
doesn't fall down and we don't have the
equivalent for governments and if we did
maybe that would help a lot and I think
we're talking about that and Larry
alluded to it well the this organization
that Larry's talking about prom we've
given them some money and they're
actually doing surveys of not the input
or the output but the throughput of
education to see whether kids are
actually literate not whether the
government says they are or whether the
school teachers say they're because
parents who are not literate can't gauge
the literacy of the education that the
kids are getting so there's there's
really three parts to this first I want
to say a nice thing about the government
of India you know they've got three one
hundred billion dollar programs to
address issues of intractable extreme
poverty and one of them is a program
called the Right to Information Act you
know we have one of those in the United
States but this one has teeth in it if
you don't get your grain allotment that
you were entitled to you go to any
magistrate and you say I didn't get my
grain allotment they have 30 days to
tell you who touched that grain
allotment at every single way in the
Train and if any one of those guys
doesn't tell you what they did with it
they go to jail and they actually make
people go to jail it's an amazing piece
of legislation likewise they
right-to-work Act where the government
has allocated a hundred billion dollars
for people in India who you know on
average can 300 million people earn less
than a dollar a day
so they have offered anyone a dollar a
day of work for two hundred days two
hundred dollars a year
but the problem is corruption the
problem is it's the leakiest pipe in the
world when you start off with a hundred
billion dollars in Delhi and you've got
to get it to a village or in any other
place in India so they built the best
program evaluation system I've ever seen
it's called a social audit forget about
where the money started or how it gets
there at the end of the day they bring
all of the landless peasants together
who were entitled to get this work and
get paid and they pull out the roster
and they check the thumb prints on the
roster in front of 2,000 villages I I
attended some of these myself where
corrupt individuals would just put in
jail immediately in front of everybody
and thousands of people cheered because
they'd never felt so empowered I think
these are some of the things that we
need to be looking at there are lots of
solutions out there the other part of it
is that I don't think people in Ghana
know what the people in India are doing
I don't think there's much of what the
UN used to call T cdz technical
cooperation amongst developing countries
we with our technology and others should
be able to spot those things which work
in one place and share it with everybody
you can be very optimistic if you go to
a social audit an Indian I'll tell you
sir did you want to jump in yeah I do
have I think that the u.s. even today
remains a leader in many ways and I do
think that if the u.s. transitions to
clean I think a lot of these other
countries will follow corruption aside
now today I do think unfortunately the
other countries are leading the u.s. and
if you look at you know they may be
small examples but Bhutan that I
mentioned or Costa Rica or any number of
others I mean these countries are using
renewables they're true they're
preserving their environment
they're actually the leaders today it's
it's a minority but but I think we need
to get the United States in the loop and
I think then the majority of countries
will follow could I
for Kyle from Boise Schiller boy
children flex to a law firm in New York
regulatory policy Al Gore mentioned the
externalities issue and really this is
what we need to focus on in the US you
were talking why how do how does it
happen how can we be optimistic well
lawyers as you know are designed to make
things slow down or potentially speed
them up on the right side let me give
you some positives Tom Friedman was
pessimistic about where we are here in
the US about shifting over internalizing
the costs of coal and oil and gas but
some good examples tobacco it did happen
it took 30 years from the time we
learned the problem to we solve it this
was the gore administration may si with
your friend Clinton the FDA did it by
regulation by regulation ultimately did
it also seatbelts it took 30 years to
get seatbelts to internalize those costs
but it happened and it can happen here
less than 30 years especially if you
have regulatory policy that shifts a big
Harbinger here is the Supreme Court's
decision in Massachusetts versus EPA
telling the EPA indeed you have the
power and that you mate you must
regulate four gases in the environment
you must regulate did you a question and
my question is why don't we get Exxon
Mobil and all these guys to spend more
time with them win them over to the
alternative fuels argument and get a bit
a better Lobby that we now have well I
think some of those oil and gas
companies you can't have that
conversation with and some of them you
cannot and I have actually been very
impressed with BP whatever its other
problems have been there is inside of
that organization a genuine search for
alternatives you know I laughed because
it's so easy to be cynical when they say
BP beyond petroleum but I actually have
been very impressed
and that you know we have other oil and
gas companies that produce deep hydro
deep so deep deep thermal energy in the
US I don't think that's an impossible
quest there's some people here today
dead in a year again and others who've
been trying to get that conversation
going and to keep it going but I do
believe that you're better going around
these companies going to their customers
letting their customers know that if you
go down this road you're endangering
your children's lives in the future I
think that's a better role for people
who are trying to advocate change then
confirm you need help and customers are
a really good group to have help you
Van Jones and you had a question
then Van Jones green for all Oakland
California this is what you just make an
observation you know we are thinking
about how do we expand this coalition
how do we get more people to care about
buying the good clean stuff and actually
more people who want to put the right
price on the dirty stuff and often these
conversations become what's wrong with
everybody what everybody get this lost
in the past year past three months talk
to 30,000 people about climate change in
places like Oakland Watts Newark we talk
about poor people in other countries you
mentioned talking about for people in
the developing countries this is what
gets people's attention if you tell
people who already live in crisis about
another crisis they get depressed okay
you're poor you don't have a house you
don't have a job you're scared and you
say here's global warming's gonna kill
everybody they don't want to join your
group oh yes don't and they say it's the
end times the juice is gonna come back
and they give up okay but if you tell
people who live in crisis about the
opportunity they get very excited so we
started telling people about the idea of
green collar jobs for their kids that we
could put low-income urban youth to work
putting up those solar panels
the president signs the law the presents
not gonna put up one solar panel
presents not gonna weather-wise one
building your kid could do that and we
got instant cooperation and support
across the board so I think what we've
got to do is stick to the positive I do
think we're gonna have to get the
government to help the markets and help
the technologies work because the
government has to be involving a
political movement that includes
everybody but if we go to people who
have crisis and telling about the
opportunity we can we can expand this
coalition to include the people who need
this green wave to lift all boats now
let me ask you a question yeah um if you
could ask one thing of the Google
founders in google.org that would help
the green collar movement what you know
what could they do
well I think that the most important
thing is that these we tend have these
conversations I got a lot of these
meetings and it's all about the
technology it's all about the
entrepreneurs and that's great but what
about the workers if you go to your if
you have the standard that says we want
three three cents that's the outcome and
we also want X number of jobs tell us
how we're going to be able to get X
number of jobs out of your innovation
and we'll make that a part of what we
celebrate you suddenly have changed this
conversation because people aren't just
thinking oh it's good for the polar
bears say hey maybe it's good for me and
my child thank you thank you yeah I'll
get to everything go over here hi I'm
Jeff Jarvis and I just blog at Buzz
machine comm I'm hearing a cultural
shift here which goes right for what
then just said and what you said a
little earlier Larry that so much of the
movement tells us what we should not be
doing you're talking about what we can
and should do and will do and I think
that's essentially different in the
message it goes back to what you said
the beginning Larry about about how good
a job were to get the message out so if
you take that essential message of
saying okay there's things we shouldn't
do fine but there's all these things we
can do and should do the technology will
bring us that I think requires lobbying
for investment it requires PR to get the
people to understand the need for
investment
it requires education how much does that
fit into is that your job or are you
going to answer the technology where
does the lobbying the information age
come in can I just add one thing to that
Jeff which is a really important point
because Al Gore and I were talking about
this on the way over I don't think
people fully appreciate what a number
Exxon Mobil did on this debate because
basically what they did is that they
made the debate between no climate
change and Al Gore so so Al was out here
at one extreme and no climate change was
here when in fact al is actually at the
center and the real debate is between
kind of Al and L which is L in the
center or actually much worse climate
change which what we're now seeing and
that's why I keep coming back to this
issue to name something is to own it
they own that debate still and what are
we gonna do to to rename it
well you it's not just ExxonMobil it's
not just that issue the coal industry in
the US has just launched a 50 million
dollar television campaign the Coalition
for fair and yeah clincal well they're
running they they don't have a name
clean coal they've got have a name which
sounds like peace motherhood and God an
apple-pie that's what the name that
they've used but it's not what they're
doing there they're trying to persuade
people that just keep using dirty coal
for a while we'll clean it up that's
really what they're trying to say and we
don't want I think that the issues
become far more manageable when we deal
with issues of getting the information
out there everybody's got to play it a
different role then can play one role
John Doerr one of our leaders played one
role al plays a role I think our role is
best played by getting all the
information out there in any way that we
possibly can because when everyone has
that same amount of information not
everybody most people are going to make
the right decision and that's what I
believe in but what happens when you're
up against people whose motto is do harm
yeah you you those people have customer
we have the gigawatts for example goals
so you know we could buy a data center
at roughly the same cost as we could get
it from coal we would go do it and we
you know we can invest capital to do it
you don't have those alternatives and if
you did everybody would do that
so far if you build it they will come
yeah I wanted to generally take issue
with something you said Larry getting
all the information out there and
letting people see all the facts and
make up their minds that that generally
works I think that's the way the world
used to work I don't think it works that
way anymore and the reason why the
tobacco industry was able to continue
killing people for 40 years after the
Surgeon General's report of 1964 is that
they understood that as against the
Enlightenment model of putting the facts
on the table seeking the best evidence
having a reasonable debate appealing to
the rule of Reason and letting people
make their minds up they understood the
power of strategic persuasion and they
went about it in a very careful
organized and well-funded way and and
the memoranda that have come out in
these lawsuits that go back 4050 years
now make it very very clear that they
knew exactly what they were doing now
the the information ecology of modern
society especially in a country like the
United States makes us vulnerable to
strategic persuasion campaigns if the
other side assumes that all we need to
do is put the facts out there let people
make up their own minds let's have an
open debate that's not it just doesn't
work that way just yesterday there was a
report on the run-up to the invasion of
Iraq with identified 975 false
statements in a concentrated period of
time with the same memes used
intentionally by the administration
again I'll give the same disclaimer I
did in the earlier session I've lost my
objectivity so take it with a grain of
salt
but this was a strategic
and pain now on on global warming on the
climate crisis
ExxonMobil is only one of those involve
the Southern Company they're they're a
bunch of them they spend a lot of money
this current 50 million dollar
advertising campaign they're sponsoring
the debates among the candidates okay uh
and ExxonMobil has funded 40 different
front groups that have all been a part
of a strategic persuasion campaign - -
in their own words reposition global
warming as Theory rather than fact now
we can be moan this and we can continue
to assume that all we have to do is to
get the facts out there and people are
capable making up their own minds or we
can counter it with a strategic
persuasion campaign that is based on the
truth and and and get that out there I
have long since come to the conclusion
that that's what's needed and that's why
I formed this alliance for climate
protection bipartisan not endorsing any
candidates or any political party but
but to take them on goddammit I've got
with a model from Zimbabwe who as well
as try to make sure when we depress
poverty we include poor people in the
debates I want to push a couple of
paradigm shifts that are required for
there to be no tension between the
poverty debate and the climate change
debate the first one is to say there
must be and there is a business case to
address the climate change debate second
paradigm shift Africans poor people must
take responsibility for their own
circumstances in Africa we're moving
away from the blame game we are
responsible for the chaos in Africa must
take charge of our lives paradigm shift
number three move away from aid to
economic investment we want investment
in Africa she chose how to fish don't
give us fish paradigm shift number four
move away from commodity based economics
to manufacturing to a processing to
value addition that's what we want so
that there's no tension between
the eradication of poverty and climate
change paradigm shift number five para
holiday from investor of Michigan the
bottom of the pyramid the economics can
be the same you need to be creative and
innovative around the bottom of the
pyramid technology volume driven
strategies how you service commerce
how you service Zimbabwe how you say
this poor communities requires
innovation around volume innovation
around technology clean technologies
clean fuels so that we can leapfrog from
the 19th century where we are through
the digital economy we need to also need
to make a shift I think that we are so
much obsessed about national sovereignty
and I want to challenge and I've already
said my views to our vice-president go
you can't address what you're trying to
do if you're obsessed of national
sovereignty we did a strategic shifts
from national sovereignty to global
sovereignty to collective humanity what
are we doing to move ourselves towards
global sovereignty and collective
humanity thank you I would just say one
thing about what Al Gore said first it's
under any circumstances it's wonderful
having a conversation with you whether
we agree or not but we do agree and you
know that we attended a meeting together
in Aspen in fact John was there as well
and it was a very depressing meeting we
just seen the latest results of the IPCC
we just seen some of the devastating
increasing of acceleration of climate
change that meeting probably if it
concluded on two things was one we
needed a tax on carbon the other we need
a total change in human consciousness
now one of those things is easier to
accomplish than another but I'm not sure
which one of them and and in this debate
and I think your analysis was exactly
and I so much appreciate your passion
the the question though is each one of
us has got to find a role that we can
uniquely play you have to look where you
stand I mean what Peggy's got is a
hundred years of moral credibility to
bring to the battle with the Rockefeller
family somebody asked me him analytical
capability others might really have
political power some might have
scientific excellence or technological
competence I ask each one of us to look
at our own assets don't do a net worth
statement do a self worth statement and
see how you can contribute what fits you
in what you do may not fit somebody else
this will turn the conversation around a
little bit but if the equation is R E is
less than C and we say that raising C
can help accelerate that and that
raising C is this is the thesis of the
question is in policy and politics I'd
like your permission to post question at
Tom Friedman he's writing a book about
this and his world expert on politics
policy globally what's your prescription
how the hell are we gonna get the policy
to be heart-attack serious and tend to
be done quickly and effectively before
is Al has warned us and led us where I'm
I thought I think I know about the re
less the innovation on the technology
the policy that you talked about
politics and this is a really unique
problem which is that historically the
environmental movement has really been
about stopping things you know stopping
pollution stopping acid rain I'm an
actually social reform movements
historically have been about you know
stopping discrimination against women
stopping discrimination against blacks
this is a very different challenge we
actually have to have a mass social
movement that gets the government to put
on attacks to set a price on carbon it's
an unprecedented thing social movement
but I like the way Al's really been
talking about I think again language is
so important that this has to be a
social movement foreign investment in
our future
if it's a social movement for a tax
that's gonna be a really hard sell but
if it's a social movement for an
investment
really what what Larry and Sergey and
Larry been saying that if we can reframe
this is how do we invest in our future
because we can talk about everything
here without a price signal you will not
have scale without scale you have a
green hobby I like to build model
airplanes for hobby not not try to get a
gigawatt of clean energy can I add one
thing to that though I mean I think
that's what we're doing the getting the
C part up but I do think there's pretty
obvious path to getting the REE part
down a lot and in order to solve some of
the development issues we really need
cheaper energy and so if you just
increase C you know in confusing if you
can't wave your hands today and increase
C a lot you know you should do that but
that that's actually not the only thing
we need to do even if you accomplish
doing that you've really missed
something important which is that we
really want everybody to have a lot of
energy okay yeah no I agree but I think
if there's one thought I want to lead
people with those that I think the
number number of people in the world
that are trying to make REE really small
is very very small like if we could
probably fit them all into this room and
that's a really serious problem you know
if we make that if we make it go from a
hundred to 10,000 people we're gonna
make a lot more progress but just to
quickly add I do think we need policy
work just to make our e smaller or to
not increase it I mean the tariffs on
the sugarcane ethanol is the real issue
the inability to put up windmills
because you just five miles off the
coast and Tucket they don't look so
pretty you know all those things are
real obstacles we need to get rid of
those just our buildings too you know we
have to attach the panels to the right
building or we can't meter it into the
grid and they won't let us connect to it
this is stuffs garbage I mean so some of
the some of the I think what circuit is
saying is to get real fast action on
these things you got to be able to
connect stuff to the grid without it
taking two years and stuff that's a
policy issue and one small thing just to
remind us what we already know
if you're looking at already less than C
it's all over the world so you might be
able to affect the price of coal by
internalizing in the United States if
you don't affect that formula in
or India you're really winning a Pyrrhic
victory we have to have re lesson see in
those countries just one data point out
that suggests maybe you've been more
successful than you know in Sanford's in
California recent public survey on
concern about climate change four out of
five Californians are willing to support
strong action on climate change not
broken down by party but by level of
knowledge that is the the four who are
supporting it no more than the one who
doesn't and so it really is in part a
matter of knowledge now that is in part
because of you because of our governador
in California who's done a pretty decent
job of educating the people of
California so it does suggest that at
least some effort at informing the
public may actually have some genuine
political consequences so that we have a
real consensus in California on action
and so I think what you're doing to
bring the message to people already is
having that kind of impact but here's a
here's a crucial distinction what you
say is absolutely right it's the result
of a lot of hard work on the part of
many many people but even though the
polls show that increase in changed
opinion here's this here's the bad part
of that when you give the American
people a list of 25 issues and you ask
them to order them in ranked priority
order climate is still not above 23 out
of on the list of 25 so there's a
difference between changing opinions and
changing the sense of urgency and that's
we need a strategic mass persuasion
campaign focused on getting that up to
the top of the list that happened in
Australia and that's why Kevin Rudd was
elected it needs to be hat it needs to
happen in the US and and elsewhere and
to make it global that's what Copenhagen
is all about the in December of 2009
Copenhagen marks the culmination of the
global process where and that's the
policy framework within which our less
than C can be locked in globally please
a little lady behind you I'm sorry
please identify yourself my name is
Chieko mori I'm an architect I'm a chair
by department of architecture at Harvard
and I have this issue about how to
represent this information to make the
knowledge more accessible to public not
only for this country because earth may
be flat but I think it's dynamic it's
very different world now thanks though
the issues brought up by climate change
poverty issues we have to come up with a
different model to inform the public as
an architect we see buildings at the
organic elements connecting many
different dots issues that incredibly
atomized issues of food to poverty to
disaster the climate how the lightbulb
to polar bears it's so diverse and I
think the problem is the people cannot
see the whole picture
and connecting millions of dots and what
I propose what Google can do with a
search engine capability is can you come
up with a dynamic mod model simulation
model which may be more visual so that
everybody can see when they actually
understand what about this one seat in
Africa how does it affect everything
else and people can see immediately how
everything is interrelated it's a
different different world and I think
that's why we are suffering from this
and that's why people don't understand
if you show this model to politicians
they will get it immediately because
it's all about improving the quality of
life and that is common issue globally
and I think this gap of how to
inseminate information is missing and I
hope that Google can come up with a very
powerful engine and very creative way to
deliver dynamic world message I think
it'd be great to have some of that
capability in Google Earth where you
could actually see simulations of what's
likely to happen and how it affects
different people and all those things we
should mention there are already layers
in Google Earth that do some of those
things for example you can look at the
effects of sea-level change and you can
simulate you know 1 meter 3 meter rise
in sea levels and it's very dramatic
they can see renewable projects around
the world so we do have some of those
pieces already no that's true we don't
have a global simulation that connects
it all I'm sorry and then you then do
symptoms you very quickly Matthew
Anderson from BSkyB in the UK there's
one opportunity that I'd also like to
add to the table and that is that each
year marketers spend about three
quarters of a trillion dollars on
advertising and marketing that is a huge
multiple of fifty million for coal and
the chance to mobilize customer bases is
huge the crisis we have from a consumers
perspective is lack of choice it's very
hard to buy products that are exciting
that are cleaner so I really think that
particularly with your relationship with
advertisers which is so important and
your relationship empowering consumers
to make choice at that level you have a
wave that's in the trillion dollar scale
as a young global leader we've just
written a book that has 15 case studies
of companies that have cut carbon
increased profit and now we're creating
a multiplication factor through their
customer base and I think this is a
great new level lever that I hope we
also embrace that business has a role to
play not just on big scale things not
just on telling people to change their
lightbulbs but in really accelerating
customer choice through the system we
could have little hats that are green
listen Roenicke from our mat we are in
renewable energy I just wanted to add
two points to this important debate
about poverty and climate change and
this is because we know that to to
reduce poverty we need energy evolve and
there are 12 very important elements one
there is still 50% of the population in
the world and probably more in poor
population in villages and the whole
movement from a village to town the
organization everybody in the village
for the same level of living meets
matchless energy then when he moves to
Islam in in a town so I think this is a
point which is very important to address
how do you do it by improving the
standard of living in the village you
will need much less energy two examples
one example is cooking cooking this
deforestation introducing a solar cooker
which have been tried for at least 40
years there is a social problem people
in Africa cook at night in the villages
because this is for the women so you
need anthropologist in social workers to
convince people to cook during today
it's not a question of man it's really
not expensive and the other was mention
of course seeds have to cut more trees
because I think we have to close the
dams I know if you want to answer that
or if you guys want to say anything in
closing well first of all this is a
wonderful conversation then and the best
part of it is not the people up here
it's the people there it's really
wonderful you from this perspective to
hear what you guys say and to feel the
passion and commitment in the room I
don't think that would have been the
case five years ago so thank you guys
and just one item I'd like that you know
we're trying to do our bit and we're
optimistic but re less than seeing the
investments where we're making but this
is obviously a global challenge and
there are so many people here and other
places doing really great and important
work you know I don't think that I think
we're you know really a drop in the
bucket and I really appreciate what
everyone's doing thank you thank you
very much